the Joe Rogan experience Sicario that
movies a card okay yeah those people are
looking at that movie so a lot of the
followers just suspicious of that
Vinicio total having an mp5 I was the
only Mexican rocking an mp5 submachine
gun down there right so it's like is
that you know what did you think of
those movies horrible horrible
unrealistic you know they should if
somebody doesn't hire me I'll do it for
free just you know I'll consult for free
on that and I'll make it look a bit more
closer to what it is but it's the main
thing is how how I everybody saw that
movie and that that's how they would you
know that's that's the reality
you know how fiction is kind of a basis
for reality so Sicario to comes out and
it's basically the United States
declaring the cartels a terrorist
organization you know and I saw that and
I was like hmm
usually fiction kind of pre kind of has
a way of influencing reality further on
the line you know that Denzel Washington
movie called siege were budget
terrorists attacked New York and then
militarized New York and that's kind of
like a president for 9/11 mm-hmm so you
see Sicario too and then you know we're
gonna terrorists Trump now says they're
gonna just thinking about declaring the
cartels as a terrorist organization
that's pretty interesting
mainly because realistically Mexico has
been calling them terrorists forever
yeah what did you think about that about
Trump doing that do you think that that
actually is something that can happen if
you're gonna militarize efforts against
it and not just consider two law
enforcement type situation I think
people should be afraid down there if
you do go that route but just realize
that's gonna be open warfare not in a
foreign country across the ocean that's
gonna be right next to your border yeah
where people can walk across yes or make
things happen down there that will
affect you up here yeah in a very real
way you know and it'll get ugly before
it gets better
you know III hopefully doesn't you know
but that's realistically but if that
doesn't happen if they don't treat it as
a terrorist organization and try to have
some sort of imp
Donna what could be done I mean I think
I think culturally they're trying to get
us ready for that you know hmm I don't
know I mean I think that's what's that's
what's happening you see a lot of the
cross you know borders US military
assets training Mexican Marines down
there and having a open relationship
with them you see that and that the push
is to maybe you know preparing for
something you know I think they're
preparing for something you know what
what could that be I don't know
so the what we get about it publicly is
just a small sliver of the actual
conversations that are being had yeah
and and also there's a lot of you know
misdirection there's a lot of
misdirection and then I'm personally
[Laughter]
[Applause]